et bonjour merci notre art direct avec
moi sur arte france votre réaction après
donc cette annonce du second tour des
municipales qui se déroulera le 28 juin
oui c'était une annonce attendue
évidemment le 28 juin parce qu' il
fallait conclure cette séquence des
municipales les équipes qui ont fait
campagne attendait cela alors il n'y a
pas de consensus au sein des différents
partis mais bien entendu tout dépend de
l'avis du conseil scientifique et de
l'état de l'épidémie quinze jours avant
le scrutin
on a tous en mémoire le premier tour
bien entendu avec ce confinement qui est
arrivé dans la foulée avec ses
assesseurs et ses différents personnes
qui ont tenu les bureaux de vote qui
sont tombés malades ou qui sont décédés
pour certains donc évidemment que
l'angoissé là alors en entendant la
déclaration d'edouard philippe et
christophe castaner on voit bien qu'ils
essayent de mettre toutes les chances de
leur côté pour que le scrutin s'organise
dans toutes les conditions sanitaires
possible et éviter un nouveau fiasco
donc on peut voir la multiplication sans
doute deux des mesures pour le vote par
procuration faudra être vigilant par
rapport à ça mais ça pose la question
bien entendu de cette continuité
démocratique avec une campagne d'un mois
qui va être très particulière ces
municipales 2020 elles ne sont pas comme
les autres ça a été dit par le premier
ministre elles sont vraiment
particulière elle pose question
finalement de la légitimité de ces
scrutins
sachant le nombre de gens qui ne sont
pas forcément aller voter ou bien la
façon dont les procurations vont être
récupérés et qui va aller voter à ce
second tour
donc beaucoup de questions en suspens on
verra quel sera l'état de l'épidémie le
28 juin mais avec ces mesures annoncées
avec aussi le fait que les français ont
bien intégré les gestes barrière depuis
maintenant plusieurs jeux enfin 55 jours
de confinement et et au delà on peut on
peut évidemment se dire qu' il n'y a pas
plus de danger à aller voter que à
ouvrir un centre commercial comme
beaugrenelle donc s'ils ont des confine
progressivement
il détend effectivement 2d confiner la
démocratie également mais la question
reste est ce qu'on peut juger ces
élections légitimes compte tenu de bien
de cette crise sanitaire majeure et de
la façon dont le premier tour a eu lieu
et puis à quoi au 6 mars
bhl est tout simplement la campagne
électorale côté candidats comment est ce
qu'on fait campagne quand on ne peut pas
serré demain quand on ne peut pas
s'approcher à moins d'un mètre cinquante
de ses électeurs
ben on ne fait pas campagne normalement
donc c'est pas sur les réseaux à la
numérisation ne va pas aider
rappelez vous lors du premier tour agnès
buzyn avait utilisé le phoning manière
assez surprenante où tout le monde avait
reçu un appel d'agnès busin même sans
demander rien du tout donc l'achat de
deux listes le mailing massif comme
disait christophe castaner des
professions de foi plus détaillée
évidemment une campagne de cette façon
là c'est pas une vraie campagne et ça
donne une prime évidente au sortant qui
a plus de visibilité de fait parce qu'il
est déjà à l'exécutif municipal est
installé donc il a plus de visibilité
par rapport à la défense de son bilan
mais aussi les journaux d'information à
des municipalités qui continuent
d'arriver dans les boîtes aux lettres
donc il ya une vraie avant ce qui est
injuste pour la cette prime aux sortants
qui va aider nombreux de deux mères déjà
installé à être réélu sans trop d'effort
est la tenue du premier tour le 15 mars
à la veille de l'annoncé du confinement
avait été marqué par un bond en massif
de l'abstention qui avait dépassé l 55%
des électeurs est ce que c'est aussi là
ce qui pointe pour le second tour tout à
fait tout à fait avec le risque bien sûr
d'avoir toute une catégorie de des
lecteurs les plus âgés les plus fragiles
qui vont éviter les bureaux de vote de
toute façon qu'ils vont pas forcément
faire des procurations et puis rappelez
vous cette idée aussi de faire des
procurations massive dans les ehpad dans
différents centres d'hébergement de
personnes âgées pose la question aussi
de la façon dont sont bien recruter ces
procurations
donc il y a une vraie question sur le
qui sont les gens qui vont aller voter
quel pourrait être le taux d'abstention
qui risque d'être assez énorme aussi
parce que la perte d'intérêt aussi dans
la campagne
cette campagne longue
abandonné arrêté qui reprend qui ne
reprend pas vraiment puisque ce ne sera
pas une campagne physique ça ça pose
vraiment questions sur la sincérité du
scrutin
le vouloir à tout prix une continuité
démocratique alors que la crise
sanitaire est la priorité
ça pose question on aurait peut-être pu
avoir une année blanche aujourd'hui il
ya des conseils municipaux installent et
ils font le travail
n'empêche pas de voter des budgets alors
cette question bien sûr d'avoir des
nouveaux budgets de relancer l'économie
donc il faut vite installer de nouvelles
équipes municipales et des communautés
de communes
ça peut se comprendre mais la question
reste on ne pourra pas aller voter sans
une garantie sanitaire et cette garantie
sanitaire ne sera jamais à 100 % le
risque zéro n'existera pas dans les
bureaux de vote
merci beaucoup pour votre réaction
alexis poulain journaliste et
cofondateur du monde moderne